[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous les 20h25 on est
en direct non touche pas mon poste c'est
c'est l'émission a beaucoup de succès
oui et ell va en avoir encore plus
maintenant puisqu'on va parler de Harry
megéan Kate
William toute la famille royale qui
règle ses comptes et oui les chées les
explications de Bertrand des KERS qui
est là dans un instant et il y a myiam
Palomba aussi pour un point PIPOL par
qu'on va parler de la familleidé et
vendu pas vendu le point sur la maison
de Joh la répondre dans instant pas
vendu qu'est-ce qui se passe what happen
what happen what happen on se calme he
elle redescend deux étages celle-ci
aussi euh allez on va faire un petit
recap et ensuite les chéris dans un
instant on reviendra bien entendu sur ce
drame Thomas la victime du drame de de
crepol qui sera avec nous et on aura
Jacky un très proche de Thomas qui est à
l'enterrement aujourd'hui qui était
extrêmement émouvant qui sera avec nous
dans un instant il vient exprès Jacky
qui est un des plus proches de Thomas et
son témoignage on v absolument l'avoir
ce soir et voilà ce sera un témoignage
très fort il sera avec nous tout à
l'heure en fin d'émission aux alentours
de de 20h50 les Chéries pour le moment
ça se déchire entre Harry megéan Kate
William non mais je vous le dis moi j'en
peux plus de cette famille royale non
mais je vous vous dire ça se jette des
puddings à la gueule c'est n'importe
quoi regardez recap et on en parle a
c'est n'importe
quoi alors que la ttention était déjà
palpable au sein de la famille royale et
cararie et megéan n'auraiit pas été
invité au 75 ans du roi ce mois-ci ils
ont attendu attendu attendu le carton
n'est jamais arriv un journaliste
anglais spécialiste de la monarchie
britannique qui s'apprête à sortir un
ouvrage affirme aujourd'hui que Kate et
William n'auraient plus aucun contact
avec megéan et Harry point de départ de
cette discorde leur envle pour les
États-Unis en
2020 destenenstion récemment accentué
par leur révélation explosives dans leur
documentaire et dans l'autobiographie
d'Arry har et William se sont battu et
aujourd'hui Buckingham serait presque au
bord de la R alors harryan Kate William
toute la famille royale règle ses
comptes les explications de Bertrand des
KERS ce soir dans
[Musique]
tpmpon C'est
bon allez au moins c'est deux les
Américains nous les voleront
pas va pas se raconter
d'histoire on est sûr ils seront pas
débauchésiam Palom magnifique elle vient
tous les soirs en ce moment ça va des
Racer pour les P bien
entendu les PUL en difficulté passe par
M Palomba c'est Madame raser toujours
des mauvaises nouvelles jamais des
bonnes mais toujours heureuse d'être là
et nous aussi on est toujours heureux de
la la recevoir parce que c'est toujours
un bonheur d'entendre des gens en
difficulté euh
c'est bertr des KERS j'adore cette
petite pochette là avec le drapeau
anglais anglais et vous avez vu les
chaussures cha son incroyable ah ouais
aussi la p touours à sortir ses
chaussures chausses tuas pas mis de
chaussette bah j'ai toutes petites
chaettes mal so qu'on est-ce que le slip
le slip est au couleur de
mais le zizi
oui
original alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
encore ça a poussé un peu tes cheveux ah
un tout petit peu poussé les cheveux
poussz pas tout le temps et bien
qu'est-ce que tu veux
ton univers
impitoyable c'est bon tu peux
sortir cétait pour que le grand public
comprenne mieux ma petite histoire d'un
côté vous avez vous souvenez de cette
série incroyable qui était Dallas vous
avez Bobby et Pamela dans le rôle de
Harry et Méane les gentils et de l'autre
côté vous avez J et souéen à savoir
William et k dans le rôle des méchant
bah c'est la version que nous propose
HID Scoby dans le livre qu'il sort à
partir du 1er décembre chez nous qui
sera disponible en France il nous dit
reviens en tout cas voilà il revient on
va vivre la main dans la main il éclaire
il tente d'éclairer différ et bien la
mort d'Élisabeth I et les semaines et
les mois qui ont suivi en nous disant
dans le fond et ben que méchant William
méchante quê méchant Charles I tout le
monde a été contre Harry et Méane alors
tout n'est pas à
jeté pas à jet dans ce qu'il a plein de
choses vraies oui oui oui il y a des
choses qui sont totalement vraies en
effet ce que je veux je tente simplement
d'apporter c'est que c'est son regard à
lui et qui a aussi beaucoup
d'inexactitude il dit par exemple par ça
mie que le jour de la mort d'éisabeth 2
Harry arrive à bord d'un charter oui
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai du tout il
prend un vol
privé mais ça fait beaucoup mieux pour
de dire alors c'est des petites
inexactitudes c'est je veux dire il
remet oui mais comme d'habitude il il
revisite la chose à par qu' paraît qu'il
l'aurait pas attendu et donc du coup il
a pas pu dire au
revoir à sa maman
grandmè excusez-moi maisabeth 2
Elisabeth 2 tu te souviens elle mort le
8 septembre 2022 et personne ne s'attend
à sa mort lorsqu'elle commence à aller
mal on rappelle les Winsor en effet
pourquoi arrivent-il en retard pourquoi
arrivent-ils tous en retard remettons
les pu l'or parce que Harry Harry
monopolisse l'avion qui a été affré
spécialement et cet avion ne peut pas
déconner pourquoi parce que il négocie
il tente d'avoir Mégane à bord de
l'avion il veut que Méan Vienne avec
pour rendre un dernier adieu à Elisabeth
2 mais non Charles 3 dit on limite
comme ça
pour n'orte
quoi il tente de revisiter
deot il y a 2 ans ma mère aussi elle a
perdu ses clés hier regarde ça va mieux
mais c'est bon calme
son bon arrête d'être comme ça prends un
peu de
recul
r'ous mais c'est
vra
il y a un truc fou c'est carry il a pris
la mort de sa grand-mère par la BBC mais
oui parce qu'il était dans dans le
fameux jet privé dont je parle et il il
était pas au courant puisque Charles a
tenté de le joindre comment voulez-vous
téléphoner à quelqu'un qui est dans
l'avion donc il a pas attendu cet appel
en eff fait c'est pas par la BBC en
réalité c'était qui sort des
notifications sur son téléphone voilà
mais mais voilà mais tout ça est amené à
nouveau c'est une guerre à terne on en
peut plus on n peut plus des C seex mais
on en peut plus des Winsor non plus moi
j'en ai r le B
ouais mais chiant chiant qu'est-ce que
tu veux nous dire d'autres
sont excuse-moi c'est bon non non mais
c'est bon c'est bon mais c'est vrai il a
raison jacardos c'est vrai ils n'ont pas
été forcément sympat avec har est-ce que
c'est
syp est-ce que
c'est de venir écrire une autobiographie
de 450 pages au Chelle en carchérisant
tout le monde c'est ça
je me calme je me calme
ici qu'estce qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autre
qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autre mais tout
mais tout n'est pas à jeté en effet
parce que il pas de William un portrait
très très noir en disant que William est
un peu colérique est un peu nerveux
qu'il est déjà plus roi que le roi qu'il
ne considère pas Charles II et qu'il il
s'y voit déjà à sa place et là je crois
qu'il a raison en effet que de la part
de William il se rêverrait déjà William
d'être
maintenant moi je pense que de la part
de Charles 3 je l'ai déjà dit je sais
bien il ne faudrait pas que le règ de
Charles I s'éterniss trop parce que d'un
point de vue image Charles et Camilla
c'est pas vraiment ça et on est quand
même très nombreux à attendre William et
surtout envie que char passe sa P à
gaucheation pass sa pte à gauche voilà
j'ai envie que mais il passera pas le
relais tu crois quoi il va aller au bout
il a attendu des années avec des
oreilles co C faire quoi frère gr
jusqu'au bout et bien je vais vous le
dire moi je pense que ce qu'il pourrait
faire c'est ce serait sa seule façon de
marquer son règne Charles I ce serait le
fait qu'il il révolutionnerait la
fonction et il ferait ce que personne
d'autre n'a fait il accepterait
volontairement d'abdiquer parce qu'il
sait que l'institution royale toute
l'institution de la couronne est
affaiblie par le fait que l'image n'est
pas bonne pour l'instant il dégragit
dans les sondages
Charl il partira jamais charlesot 3 ça
fait des années qu'il attendam par col
BS arrête un peu là
ça fait des années que tuattend de
mettre le Pochat là tout ça tu crois
quoi crois qu'elle va se barrer comme
frère on dirait Mamie Nova frérot tu
crois elle va rester là frère tu CIS va
faire quoi tu crois elle va aller vendre
des yaourts mon frère bien sûr qu'elle
vaê tu crois que tu es re d'Angleterre
tu vas dire non j'arrête mais frère tu
es un ouf toi c'est mais tu es un ouf tu
crois jamais il partira Charles 3 ni
Charles 3 ni Charles 6 ni
Charles çaage que moi mais moi j'y je
pense que ce serait la seule façon Mar
son il s'en va couill et je te en
pochette non mais je te le dis
laangletre mais je te dis la du drapeau
d'Angleterre tu vas voir tu vas voir ça
va te faire tu vas voir ça mettra un
petit peu de couleur mais il est très
populaire non en
plus non non non 70 % pniblement il
dégragole il a eu un état de grâce au
moment du couronnement mais pour
l'instant ça ne l'est plus du tout en
tout cas cy c'est ce que j'espère moi
qu'il le ferait pour sauver
l'institution je ne dis pas qu' je ne
prétends pas avec certitude qu'il va le
faire je pense mais qu'il est très
réfléchi Charl 3 et ces incertitudes là
il les a il est conscient de la
fragilité de l'institution à l'heure
actuelle la il est aussi surtout
conscient que William ne supporte pas
Harry et ne pardonnera jamais à Harry ce
qu'il lui a
fait et donc sinon bah je pense que j'ai
plus ou moins terminé merci bébé merci
juste petite juste question euh non 2
minutes si on va pas le faire chier non
plus euh Harry n'a pas été invité à
l'anniversaire de son père on rappelle
oui mais ils sont parlé ils se sont
parlé ils se sont téléphoné c'était le
c'était le 14
novembre ils se sont téléphonés
absolument il av même parlé à Méan même
par la Méan les enfants ont chanté
absolument en vidéo conférence il que ça
s'est très très bien passé je le disais
tout à l'heure avec vous savez Charles
il règne avec sa tête cert mais aussi
avec son corp mais pas William William
va être un roi très froid William est le
vrai héritier d'éisabeth i Elisabeth I
avait le sang glacé et c'est Willam qui
ble glésument seul comptait le devoir le
devoir le devoir avait que la couronne
c'est William ça c'est vraiment
l'héritage de William excuse-moi j'ai
pas entendu pardon pour vous l'avez pas
décongeléab mais non mais
non tu pens que cama Parker elle kiffe
le son Rene de
dajjou je pense que par kiffe le son
reine DEJOU
là
c'est là c'était lors de la visite à
Paris elle était en rose en Hage au rang
de r au rang
de tu me souris je ne fais pas semblant
je pas besoin d'attendre plus longtemps
je sais qu'il est temps de partager mon
sort é levé au R de rêve alors on va se
retrouver dans un St avecam Palom